- So is there anything we
can do to make your work
(phone buzzes)
Do you need to answer that?
- I know when that hotline bling
can only mean one thing.
(hip-hop bass thumping)
- So, how you been, man?
- You know, running through
the six with my woes.
Countin' money, you know how it goes.
- I see you were brought in to be our new
- Controlla.
- I'm sorry?
- Must be a new position.
- James, this is Matt and Kim.
They just moved to L.A.
- Hi!
- No new friends.
- (laughs) Don't listen to him,
he's not being serious.
- No new friends.
- No, no new.
- I just wanna be,
I just wanna be,
I just wanna be successful.
I want the money.
- Yes!
- Money and the cars.
- Cars and the clothes.
And the hoes.
- So, how are you
adjusting to the workflow?
- All I know, if I die,
I'm a motha (bleep) legend.
- Well, you know, it's
great to have confidence.
- I can tell that love is fake.
I don't trust a word you say.
How you tryna clique
up after your mistakes?
Look you in the face,
and it's just not the same.
I've been down so long,
it looks like up to me.
- Can I tell the truth?
- Of course.
- If I was doing this for you,
I'd have nothing left to prove.
- Well, it's not about me.
It's about the company.
- Nah, this for me, though.
I'm just tryna stay alive
and take care of my people.
And they don't make no award for that.
- No, no, no, no, no, they
don't.
(exhausted sigh)
- Now, is it just me,
or is this sex so good
I shouldn't have to (bleep) for free?
(smack)
- I need a one dance.
- Excuse me?
- One more time 'fore I go.
- Where are you going?
- Higher powers taking control.
- This is an evalua...